one year ago the central chinese city of
wuhan went into what was then an
unprecedented lockdown 11 million people
were isolated from the rest of china and
the world
in a desperate attempt to prevent the
spread of a deadly coronavirus
that attempt failed cases were quickly
identified in thailand
japan and south korea and the united
states began restricting travelers from
china
in wuhan authorities built makeshift
hospitals to treat
thousands suffering from the illness the
world's second largest economy
was at a standstill as authorities
fought to contain the outbreak
in february the virus was officially
named covert 19
and europe faced its first major
outbreak a surge in cases in italy
spurred a lockdown
in lombardi while it also arrived in
iran
on the 11th of march the world health
organization declared a global pandemic
we have never been before seeing a
pandemic sparked by
a coronavirus this is the first pandemic
caused
by a coronavirus and
we have never before seen a pandemic
that can be controlled at the same time
the number of coronavirus infections
around the world now exceeds 100 million
and more than 2 million people have died
the us
brazil and india have recorded the
highest number of deaths
more than 50 countries are now racing to
inoculate their populations
several vaccines have been approved for
use internationally
but poorer countries are struggling to
secure doses
meanwhile fast spreading virus mutations
are raising concerns over vaccine
efficacy
concerns health experts are trying to
address
there's a thing called a cushion effect
so if you have a vaccine like the
moderna and the fisa vaccine
that can suppress the virus at a
dilution let's say of
one to a thousand and the mutant
influences it by bringing it down to
maybe one two
to eight hundred or something like that
you're still
well above the line of not being
effective
in china months of tough measures and
closed borders have seen the outbreak
largely controlled
but in the north authorities are now
battling resurgent cases
in beijing mass testing and tracing
measures have been reimposed
they're not alone countries previously
lauded for lower numbers of infections
have reintroduced restrictions
due to increases in cases 2021 may be a
new year
but the who has warned that the global
fight to contain crovid 19
is far from over katrina yu al jazeera
beijing